heute hier plaudere ich mal aus dem
nähkästchen ist wieder eine dieser
sendungen wo du von anfang an weist die
kriegst du auf jeden fall voll
denn seit heute vormittag läuft der 70
ordentliche bundesparteitag der fdp
meine damen und herren eröffnet
natürlich von christian lindner aber
ganz ehrlich wen interessiert
wir von der heute show warten immer auf
die legende auf wwu die renschler
und er hat auch heute wieder den laden
gerockt ich stehe sehr gerne mal wieder
hier
wir sind hier in der hauptstadt der
enteignungs gefahr heute kommst du noch
vom fleck morgen ist dein auto weg
[Musik]
wie glauben braucht die drohne willigen
auto der kann noch fliegen aber lassen
sie sich von rudis extremer niedlichkeit
bitte nicht täuschen bei den liberalen
gibt es gerade heftige diskussionen
manche finden nämlich die partei
wiederholt ihre alten fehler und kommt
schon wieder zu kaltherzig rüber sie
soll doch empathischer werden gefühle
zeigen ist inzwischen ja völlig neue
herausforderungen gefühle gerade
christian lindner fällt das wahnsinnig
schwer
er würde gerne empathisch rüberkommen
aber dann fragte in einer nach
demonstrierenden schülern und dann
rutscht ihm wieder so was machen sie
nicht großkotzig ist raus kann man von
kindern erwarten dass sie alle globalen
zusammenhänge das technisch sinnvolle
und das ökonomisch machbaren sehen ich
behaupte herr lanz sie und ich sehe noch
nicht mal alle globalen zusammenhängen
ja ja ja wirklich wie oft hat sich
stephen hawking gedacht ich verstehe die
globalen zusammenhänge nicht ich rufe
besser markus lanz an
oder den lindner die fdp muss
tatsächlich irgendwie ja freundlicher
lieber werden aber gut exakt dafür exakt
dafür wen sie ja an diesem wochenende
ihre neue generalsekretär in linda
teuteberg die ist vielleicht empathisch
und genau in der mitte
in der mitte zwischen den
extrempositionen mit vernünftige
abwägung vernünftigen argumenten aber
eben auch mit empathie möchtest du auch
noch was sagen ländern ein gut
tatsächlich hat sich die linde als
hardlinerin in der migrationsfrage
annahmen gemacht keiner bringt das wort
abschiebehaft so empathisch und warm
rüber wie sie ja wunderbar wunderbar
aber aber mal eine ganz andere frage
warum braucht die fdp überhaupt eine
neue generalsekretärin was er mit der
alten
[Musik]
nicht stimmt die brauchen eine neue ja
heute wird die länder jedes mal achten
sie darauf jedes mal wenn es um konkrete
politik geht bricht die alte fdp durch
beispiel ganz deutschland macht sich
gerade zu recht sorgen wegen
explodierender mieten ist ein
riesenthema
das wären es super gelegenheit mal
verständnis zu zeigen für diese haben
jedoch normalverdiener aber selbst
solidarität denkt bei denen irgendwie
falsch
ich bin selber mieter in berlin und weiß
also wie die probleme sind und wie die
mieten gesteht ich glaube nicht dass ihr
problem hat eine wohnung zu kriegen ja
aber auf der friedrichstraße in berlin
wäre es mir zu teuer gewesen also
nämlich aus schöneberg eine längere
anfahrt in kauf
schöneberg das schlimmste ghetto von
berlin
von da sind es fünf kilometer bis zum
reichstag hin und zurück 10
die muss der fahrer vom lindner jeden
tag fahren denken sie da mal drüber nach
greif herziges publikum beglichen
tatsächlich möchte seine fdp artikel 15
aus dem grundgesetz streichen der
enteignung von immobilienkonzernen
ermöglicht darüber diskutiert ja gerade
berlin klar
über den sinn von enteignungen kann man
durchaus streiten aber mal eben im
grundgesetz zu streichen
hier ein erster bearbeitungs entwurf der
fdp artikel eins lautet jetzt die würde
des unternehmers ist unantastbar
artikel 14 heißt das natürlich eigentum
verpflichtet zu nichts und dann haben
wir noch einen völlig neuen artikel 5
der website auf eine wohnung im
erdgeschoss
sie merken die fdp will gestalten
deswegen haben die liberalen auch eine
art geheimnis regierungsprogramm
erarbeitet das auch ausdrücklich kein
witz ready for government beispiel
sollten sich nicht ausdenken also jetzt
nur salz demnächst die groko platzt und
man die fdp brauchen sollte ready for
government wenn jamaika doch normal
anklopft man muss sich vorbereiten kommt
ins christian lindner ready volker
wiemann
und was bedeutet das dass christian
lindner reggae volker wiemann bootcamp
lieber schlecht regieren als gar nicht
dich jetzt
gestoppt wie
immerhin ich finde es gut dass die neue
fdp empathischer werden will will schaut
mal live zu sebastian pufpaff von der
gerade neu gegründeten fdp ready for
empathie taskforce herr pufpaff was
genau machen sie da jetzt ja ich stehe
hier so durch die ortsverbände und dann
arbeiten wir gemeinsam an mehr empathie
die musik erst mal nachschlagen
laut duden ist empathie die bereitschaft
sich in andere menschen einzufühlen erst
dachte ich auch cool pumpen
aber ist es nicht eben gar nicht in
andere menschen einfühlen es gibt also
menschen die sind nichtig
das neuland deshalb schauen wir uns
jetzt als praktische übung szenen an wo
man angeblich was empfinden muss hier
zum beispiel ein kind dem gerade das
kuscheltier weggenommen wurde
[Musik]
die nächste er warum heute sprang soja
der wille so bescheuert ja soll er sich
einen job suchen dann kann er sich so
viele kuscheltiere kaufen wir will das
problem ist doch die fehlende
eigeninitiative so ein arbeitsmarkt wie
jetzt hat mir noch nie war das jetzt in
basel nicht so richtig aber wegen mir
muss die fdp auch gar nicht empathisch
werden das glaubt man noch wenig an ein
challenge accepted der welt jetzt kommt
wohl eine szene da geht es um
wohnungsnot musik wein und nachschlagen
wir kommen uns dass man jetzt bekommt er
rente plus grundsicherung insgesamt 632
euro
eine wohnung kann er sich davon nicht
leisten für den campingwagen zeit der
250 euro miete strom kommt noch
obendrauf der opfer hatten campingwagen
was wir denn ich habe keinen
campingwagen herreweghe ich fühle was
neid ungerechtigkeit habt ihren
campingwagen habt ihr im gaming wagen
ich habe zwei die fresse so gar nicht
das thema jetzt ruhig ich wehre mich
vehement gegen dieses uralte teamchef
von der kaltherzigen fdp
wir setzen uns ständig für andere ein
meine partei ist die einzige die im
bundestag gegen diese unsägliche
dokumentationspflicht beim mindestlohn
kämpft deutsche unternehmer müssen immer
noch aufschreiben wie viele stunden ein
mindestwert tatsächlich für sie arbeitet
das ist bürokratischer irrsinn dass es
neben dem mangel an fachkräften die
hauptsorge der deutschen kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen
umweltauflagen statistiken dies auch
mehrfach mülltrennung achtung von
menschenrechten bekämpfung von
korruption datenschutz grund verordnung
es macht keinen spaß mehr unternehmer zu
sein zu bleiben oder zu werden
es macht es keinen spaß mehr was von
unternehmen heutzutage verlangt wird
menschenrechte einhalten sind jetzt
komplett durchgeknallt was rund zwei
millionen deutsche werden mit tricks und
den mindestlohn betrogen paketboten
dürfen zum beispiel das beladen ihres
autos nicht als arbeitszeit zählen ja
ist es auch nicht paar kartons hier von
zalando hin im kofferraum zu schmeißen
ich bitte sie ja wir gucken uns jetzt
bilder von einem hotelbesitzer an der
vom stalinistischen regime in berlin
gezwungen wird die arbeitsstunden seiner
putzfrauen aufzuschreiben
jetzt kommen muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist mit schiffen emotionen sind super
fordern unterkühlung
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße